I'm at Google cloudex 2023 and a lot of
folks are talking about platform
engineering so let's hear from product
manager Nick eberts on what it is and
how you can do it better with GK oh
platform engineering is a Hot Topic
these days right so we've got customers
that are out there building platforms
for users right and users are developers
they're data scientists and they need
and a capability to be able to scope
access to fleets of clusters so my team
this week g a product uh Fleet tency
that gives you uh Fleet aim spaces and
Scopes and RB back Bings that allow you
to to wrap um rbase access controls for
a particular set of name spaces across a
number of clusters and provide access to
a self-service environment for
developers so if you're trying to build
self-service environments and platforms
on top of gke check out the uh the
features that we shipped on fleet tency
so you heard it here first check out
Fleet tency on gke and how it can help
you build a platform